[Música]
saber que estou a pensar se você faz com
essas só seguirão nova pasta também não
estava eu quero dizer nem a all atua
eu espero que você esteja uma verdadeira
anos mais uma pergunta quem é que gosta
de matemática o quanto ela sofre hoje
nada não vou fazer nada com isso nem com
a maravilhosa catarina diz a usar dois
anos que eu tenho um canal no youtube e
eu a faz vídeos matemática mas o meu
canal não é propriamente educacional no
sentido em que o meu objetivo não é
explicar a matéria que se aprende na
escola
pelo contrário é falar de assuntos por
nos quais não há espaço na sala de aula
deus da história sobre os matemáticos
loucos as curiosidades o quebra cabeças
o que eu quero mesmo é dar um aspecto
mais jovem mais divertido fresco e bem
disposto a uma área que é por muitos
considerada difícil e estúpido água e
seca portanto que realmente dá esse
aspecto de enfrentar matemática
agora que eu já não apresentei há muito
ao falar vos de alguns motivos que eu
acho que os quais eu acho que muitos
alunos não gostam de matemática e os
quais é preciso realmente só pensar a
forma como nós ensinamos essa disciplina
e tentar conquistar o rosto que todos
temos por aprender a e inventar métodos
para ensinar matemática ou então focar
uma núcleo motivou a criar esse projeto
vou falar vos da história da minha vida
o meu pai ea minha mãe estava muito um
do outro e então decidiram construir o
meu irmão com mas até ficaram
satisfeitos com o resultado assim eles
irão consumir menin desta segunda vez
atingiram a perfeição e pararam por aí
as águas foram correndo a energia o que
é vida para quem não precisa lutar para
os anos foram passando e quando dei por
mim eu já estava na escola
se gostei de matemática sempre gostei de
aprender ali e boas notas mas só quando
eu comecei a participar nas olimpíadas
de matemática que são a competição com
mais visibilidade a nível do ensino
básico e secundário é que o meu pais nem
verdadeiramente foi a área
ao passo que na escola no chão dadas
certas ferramentas e no chão embicado
exercícios onde basta aplicar essas
ferramentas e nós não temos que pensar
muito nas olimpíadas de matemática não
tem exercícios não tenha assistido assim
problemas desafiantes em que nós temos
que ter um bom raciocínio lógico pensar
fora da caixa ter uma idéia e foi isso
um desafio com muito e vou aprender mais
aquilo era difícil e eu não estava
habituado a pensar portanto para ser
sincera mas foi realmente as olimpíadas
que o estimularam a prender mais fui que
eu me senti mesmo desafiada e portanto
muito motivada para aprender considerem
esse problema aqui
o joão ea maioria tem uma mesa circular
à sua frente
eu não e também tem um sax a seis moedas
potter infinitas moedas vocês quiserem
as moedas de só que eles têm são todas
iguais entre si e eu vou jogar o jogo da
jornada ante canção deus vai por uma
moeda em cima da mesa está a moeda da
marinha é o joão mas na maioria mas joão
ea as mães têm que ficar todos ao mesmo
nível ou seja não pode viver com elas
umas em cima das outras tantas vão
quando uma via alternadamente e perde
aquilo que já não tiver mais fácil para
colocar uma moeda
então aqui as regras para vocês nós quer
serem eu acho que toda a gente entendeu
alguém não entendeu o que estão todos
muito fértil bem a agora tem uma
campanha vou fez xixi na cama sendo
maria primeiro ajudar ela qual ter uma
estratégia vencedora
ou seja caso o nito ué quando uma moeda
em cima
nesa eventualmente a mesa tem um tamanho
infinito portanto vai me chamar de
espaço algum deus absorver se vangloria
primeiro a chegar será que ela possa
conceber uma estratégia que garanta
sempre a sua vitória com sentença que
ela vai ganhar
quando eu viajo pela própria pela
primeira vez eu pensei ah não sei se é
ser muito esquisito eu não sei qual é o
tamanho da mesa não sei qual é o tamanho
das moedas e parece não um jogo de sorte
quer dizer que não deu certo ponto uma
moeda eventualmente vai deixar de ver o
espaço e à pessoa prendeu ser a vilã a
mim mas por incrível que pareça se maria
foi muito astuta e perspicaz ela
realmente construir uma estratégia que
garante sempre a sua vitória então o que
ela faz ter ainda a atenção
ela começa por uma moeda é exatamente no
centro da mesa e depois tudo o que ela
vai fazer é copiar a jogada do
adversário ou seja ela vai julgar
symmetry caminhante em relação ao joão
por exemplo sul joão coser uma moeda
aqui ela vai pôr a noiva aqui ver esta
assimetria sul joão por 1 0 mas aqui ela
vai pôr a mão no saque
aqui ela vai pôr a mãe daqui ou seja no
fundo ela vai fazer exatamente conclusão
faz vai copiar a jogada do adversário
mas fazendo uma reflexão em relação ao
centro e que isso nos diz meu está
brilhante se o joão tem espaço para
colocar uma moeda estudo que ela faz é
imitar o joão então ela vai ter sempre
foi um espaço para colocar uma moeda
portanto vai ser um jogo que vai inchar
e vai aprender ou seja a maioria a
maioria assim conseguem ganhar e eu sei
que é um momento em que vocês devem
estar a pensar e placar em 6 em almas e
não quer pensar nisso pois não porque
pensar é uma coisa difícil e as pessoas
às vezes têm interesse na cabeça este
problema quer creative labs querem senão
ir lá e ter uma idéia sensacional
isso é matemática e isso é matemática
mas será que algum de vocês viu alguma
coisa do gênero durante o vosso percurso
escolar
não por causa entre a brilhante ideia
que é melhor começar logo enfiarmos
foram as suas moedas a mais se o ano
assim eu realmente penso que a nossa
educação e escola precisam de uma grande
reforma porque quando a maior
parte dos alunos só vai à escola por
obrigação e tenta ter boas notas por
agradar os paparazzi não era fogo no
estudo
algo está errado as coisas via ser vista
como um local ótimo para aprender sobre
vários assuntos e partilhar conhecia não
devia ser encarada como um martírio
pronto é também não vim aqui pra falar
mal dos professores até porque algumas
pessoas na platéia isso era muito antigo
climático que também não vim aqui dizer
mal do governo
simplesmente acho que é interessante nós
refletirmos acerca deste assunto
vamos pensar em que aspectos que
poderiam ser melhorados na forma como
nós ensinamos matemática a
em primeiro lugar eu acho que é
importante nós aprendermos a tabuada e
assoviar e equações e todas essas
ferramentas técnicas mas acho que a
união ficasse por aí uma dica hoje em
dia é realmente muito técnica e encarar
michael no fundo basicamente estar
formulas nos alunos
depois eu simplesmente tem de se aplicar
em exercício nos testes eu acho que isso
não sai
acho que isso não está correto há pouco
em primeiro lugar nós não estamos é
estimular o seu raciocínio
nós não está nos ensinar os a pensar
estamos a treinar macacos santo
treinando aqui rios limitação que sejam
assim o olho num canto pro lado e veio
mais ou menos como é que o professor
está a resolver um exercício e por
tentar fazer igual e às vezes até multa
não é portanto é perfeitamente possível
que um aluno chegue ao exame nacional de
matemática tem uns 8 e não posso de um
macaco vem treinando neste momento nós
não estamos a ensinar os alunos a
pensarem em segundo lugar os alunos têm
que ser motivado para aprender
nós todos nós temos concluiu errado por
saber
e essas coisas todas mas é preciso
encarar os jovens e mostrar por que é
que vale a pena aprender aquilo que se
aprenda mostrar lhes que a matemática
por exemplo é importante que acima de
tudo é divertido e em que a gente vai
estar em aprender aqui o e portanto pode
motivar os estudantes eu acho que é
preciso desafiá los porque foi isso que
aconteceu comigo eu só fiquei motivado
para aprender matemática quando
realmente senti um desafio e tanto
realmente tentar o fórum caso mais pela
parte da criatividade eo raciocínio
lógico eu acho que isso é ótimo para
motivar os estudantes é perfeitamente
natural que o jovem não fico super
entusiasmado ao calcular de março em
divisor comum durante cinco meses
consecutivos através de um algoritmo
evitado por professor
eles vêm coisas mais interessantes no
instagram
portanto nós temos singular
temos de estimular os alunos mas nós
queremos do que realmente estamos a
lidar com pessoas com seres humanos como
nós que não vão gostar de uma área só
porque eventualmente pode vir a ser útil
no futuro caso ou se uma determinada
carreira
é preciso ter isso em atenção estamos a
falar pronto estamos com jovem e temos
de cultivar é exatamente isso que eu
queria disse ele
agora é também há uma coisa que eu acho
que eu acho que é muito engraçada que é
a pessoas dizem ah e tal tu tens de
aprender matemática
portanto a temática está sempre presente
no dia a linha em tudo aquilo que faz e
portanto é muito importante aprender
então os autores manuais 65 obrigados a
colocar o exercício de funções em que a
joana tem um estranho tipo de amnésia em
que não sabe qual é a sua idade mas sabe
que daqui a cinco anos vai ter obrigado
quem há quatro anos atrás e então a
joana tem sabido resolver equações para
terminar a sua hilária
esta é irrealista e agora eu vou deixar
ficou com 12a não os dias que eu acho
que eu resume perfeitamente destas
idéias
eu estou a fazer então imagine que você
acha que entravam numa aula pintura
a professora chegava lá e dizia meninos
isso é um pincel um pincel é constituir
por um cabo de madeira e apresenta tanto
frio pneus na extremidade os pintores
recorrem os pincéis para pintar os seus
magníficos quadros pessoa funciona e
isso é que nós também vamos pintar o
fluminense ser reciclado e bonitos
lamento mas nós temos que cumprir o
programa e ainda nos falta de falar que
mais 7 134 tipos de pincéis
ou então imagine que nas aulas música
você só aprende a escrever pautas sua
pessoa eo mini internet no outro dia que
a música é uma coisa que se pode ouvir
que as pessoas gostam muito será que não
está muito podemos ouvir a oi totais
maluco e não utilizasse a ordem dos seus
níveis e já quer ouvir música
mais uma vez estamos a fazer as poucas
crianças nós estamos a ensinar as coisas
mas nós não estamos realmente mostrar
porque é campeão fc não estamos assim
molas não haver em pronto eu sei que
ainda tenho muito para aprender e não
sou motoboy ghoga nenhum gênio está
apenas a minha opinião mas a matemática
realmente o meu amorzinho eu gostava que
as pessoas olhassem por ela de uma forma
diferente e sentiram necessidade que é
preciso realmente repensar e conquistar
e e inventar métodos para para ensinar
matemática
portanto há também não fazia sentido eu
ficar por ava de braços cruzados e vir
para aqui queixar
eu tinha que fazer alguma coisa e foi
isso que eu criei foi este canal do
youtube com vídeos divertidos e com
autorização matemáticas foi isso que eu
criei por atentar no vária atrito da
sociedade faça matemática
foi isso que eu fiz pela minha quais são
e tu o que é que vai fazer por tua
muito obrigado